[Music]
really goodness thank you hanging here
yeah I fit in the turn off well let's
talk about that I noticed right away you
came out and you've lost some weight
I'm down about a hundred and ten pounds
and he's looking at me now how fat were
you you lost a Howard yes 110 pounds
uh-huh yeah we'll go to beta you
laughing yeah what motivated this : I'm
type 2 diabetic man and not a lot of
people address that they're a sick like
that and so the doctor told me look man
one of two things keep eating and
bye-bye or start losing weight and you
can be around and enjoy your career good
that's oh you you took the advice and
what was your method what did you do my
crack no get the weight off it does get
the weight off no actually I started
doing yoga man I started doing a thing
called DDP power yoga I I've heard of a
lot of kinds of yoga there's the Bikram
where you sweat there's yoga hot sweaty
wet like in a tub I've never heard of
yoga what is DDP it's a Diamond Dallas
Page professional wrestler Diamond
Dallas Page yeah he's a big fan of mine
I'm a big fan of his and he said listen
Brahman to help you out man I'm gonna
I'm gonna help you shut that weight do
my program and it's gonna it's gonna say
first well we have a picture of this
gentleman Diamond Dallas Page there he
is barely not smoking is not a problem
not part of the regimen but okay so you
talk about power yoga is it cuz it was
supposed to be very peaceful whatever is
very quiet it's very not with bdp DDP is
intense he says it very loud and clear
it's not your mama's Yoga okay it's very
intense and he yells at you the whole
time and I used to not be able to get on
the ground and now I can get down I can
get back up I can roll over I cook like
a dog
it's pretty intense I can't get up no
problem and like before if I get down I
need a chair or something to help me get
back company knows right yeah okay here
we go and now I'm on the floor I'm
rolling around it's it's pretty cool
does he have you making noises oh yeah
well for example watch I'll show you
okay now right away he would yell at you
stop doing that okay DDP yoga it's a
bunch of different moves I'll show you a
couple really quick right one you put
your feet together like this okay got
try to bring them together but don't
bring them together so you feel that
tension it sorry to touch you there but
you just want to give me not peer touch
okay yeah all right I got that though
and this is a coil okay yeah it's a it's
coarse string so and then you put your
arms out you make them tense tense
Koenen tense tense there you go real you
want to feel the tension you want to
feel it do you feel the tension I'm
kidding no now you feel it all right
yeah yeah that's so credible okay now
you put your hands together like this
okay I'm and okay I can sit up over your
head up over your head now you want to
bring your arms out tense now hook it up
[Applause]
now we could take it to the floor start
to give you my back all right now you
want to get down to the ground so
basically you want to get down to point
yeah okay okay I'm flying
are you planking yeah I'm playing I'll
come down your knees yeah all right now
you want to arch your back yeah I want
to get your butt up in the air lift up
your head nice and down you're doing a
cat this is the cat right here okay this
right here okay yes okay now you put
your toes on the ground and you lift
yourself up right this is called a Down
Dog okay this is down okay
hey is blood supposed to be filling my
pants yeah I'm gonna let you get up
before your blood runs that's that's
hope but what I just done is this this
is right now.they its core strength a
lot of people think all yoga is easy and
stuff it's not that's right out of I'm
already sweating look at that yeah I'm
having a nervous breakdown
nah man but it's a lot of it's a lot of
fun for me because I never used to be
able to be active and that was the
biggest problem is I was always a big
dude but I couldn't move around and more
than important I just want to be a life
Conan
you